the 49ers had a plan this weekend and it
worked they got trent williams away from
washington at a time when it looked like
washington had no trade partners because
the buccaneers were interested in trent
williams until they drafted a first
round tackle the browns were interested
in williams until they drafted a first
round tackle the vikings were in on
trent williams until they drafted a
second round tackle and then on saturday
when it looked like washington was stuck
and it felt like trent williams was
trying to get himself released so he
could pick his next team and get a new
contract out of the blue the 49ers get
the deal done kyle shanahan who was the
offensive coordinator in washington
reunited with trent williams the long
time left tackle there
and uh boom bang pow right after trent
williams is traded to uh san francisco
chris
joe staley announces his retirement i
kind of feel like this was all
orchestrated i kind of feel like they
knew that staley was gonna retire they
just wanted to wait until after they had
trent williams on the roster before
staley announced his retirement well
this is the kind of moves and magic they
really functional not dysfunctional but
functional organization can make you
know i think it says a lot about the
leadership of the 49ers not only you
know jed york but kyle shanahan and john
lynch that mike i mean you're right
there's no doubt they knew joe staley
was going to retire
they did a good job of keeping that
under wraps plus because they've treated
joe staley the right way and he has
respect for jed york and shanahan and
john lynch he kind of kept his mouth
quiet until they got the you know
acquired asset that they wanted for
their football team and trent williams
with the history with kyle shanahan uh i
i think probably wanted to go play for a
guy like kyle knowing you know what he
is as an offensive genius and his
ability to run the ball and uh all the
excitement around the 49ers right now so
you know this is a big time draft by the
san francisco 49ers it wasn't
necessarily that they killed it with
number of players but they got three
guys that we could all sit here and look
at and go whoa they needed these three
guys and they got high level at that
trent williams the left tackle you know
the iuke receiver because he lost
emmanuel sanders oh we traded deforest
buckner to the colts hey we got javon
kinlaw back for that pick we traded at a
much lesser price so the 49ers would be
one of those teams i would look at to
say they killed it this past weekend
and let me just say this this was gm
john lynch one week ago speaking to
reporters in the bay area
as to the prospect of joe staley playing
in 2020 we've kept in good contact with
joe he's doing his typical routine down
with his family in san diego working out
were encouraged we've heard nothing that
would lead us to believe that joe is not
going to play so we're encouraged with
that we'll see where that goes um look i
guess there's a chance that joe staley
had some sort of epiphany between monday
and saturday morning chris i think the
more likely reality is this is another
reason why
it makes sense to scratch the surface it
makes sense to not swallow the hook like
so many of us are want to do
we need to be willing to question
because there are strategic reasons for
lying to the fans for lying to the media
for ultimately lying to the team that
you're trying to get trent williams from
because if they know joe staley's
retiring right first of all if everyone
knows joe staley's retiring then you got
to be looking for a tackle in the draft
anyway
and right if they know joe staley's out
it's a lot easier to draw the
connections from the 49ers to williams
because of kyle shanahan's link between
the two teams this is brilliant and this
is why you know
people accuse me from time to time oh
you're trying to make something out of
nothing no i know that in many of these
cases there's something going on behind
what they're telling us and this is a
prime example of it
yeah a prime example let alone you know
all the things you said
added to it if the washington redskins
know for sure that joe staley's going to
retire they're going to be able to ask
for higher draft compensation in trades
because they know the 49ers are
desperate so they'll hold their feet
under the fire that way too so really
well planned out and i'm with you mike i
don't know
but i certainly would think that this
was the plan all away all along and they
got joe staley to just be a good team
guy
and keep his mouth shut act like it was
business as usual until they got what
they needed or wanted to fill his roster
spot and you know like i said the 49ers
they killed it this weekend with three
really quality big time contributors to
their football team right away got a big
time receiver and then you know kin law
adds to that great defensive line where
they're not going to lose much now
because they lost to forest buckner and
trent williams
you know before he sat out last year is
the best left tackle in football he's
he's a hall of famer he's that talented
and
that was big for the 49ers
scott mcclellan who was at one point the
general manager of the 49ers and then
the general manager in washington said
last week that trent williams is better
than any of the prospects definitely the
draft and look and that's that's really
not that much of a reach because and
this gets back to the point we were
discussing earlier for the guys coming
in we don't know who's going to work out
we don't know who's going to be able to
deal with khalil mack and aaron donald
we don't know that we know trent
williams can because we've seen that
right before
and here's another wrinkle to this chris
that i find fascinating
trent williams
reportedly put the kibosh on a potential
trade to the vikings he denies that his
agent came out not long before the trade
happened with this blanket statement
saying we've done nothing to discourage
anyone from trading for trent williams
look there had been a prevailing belief
for months that trent williams wants 18
to 20 million per year as part of a
rework contract after he's traded and we
know what that does to a trade it makes
it harder to happen because not only do
you have to play kate washington you
have to come up with a contract that
trent williams will like he wants 18 to
20 million i heard in the aftermath of
the laramie tunzel deal from late last
week that he now wants 22 million a year
well that's a way to avoid going to a
place you don't want to go to because
if you if you have that vague sense out
there you want this big raise it's going
to be impossible to get a deal done in
cleveland or minnesota or tampa bay but
then for san francisco oh what i don't
want a new contract i'm fine with it and
that's what we're hearing now he's
perfectly fine with 12 and a half
million for now and they'll deal with it
down the road i don't think any other
team was getting that consideration
which in hindsight made it even more
clear that he wanted out of washington
and he wanted to land in san francisco
he got what he wanted san francisco got
what they wanted and washington
christian this was a point you made to
me via text message and i went back and
found the old stories dan snyder surely
did not want to trade trent williams to
kyle shanahan dan snyder had to hold his
nose and take his medicine to get what
he could for trent williams no doubt i
mean i think there was some other teams
interested in trent williams for sure
mike i know i i had texted you a few of
the teams that i thought or i had heard
you know through the nfl grapevine that
were in conversation with the washington
redskins but mike i think you know your
last point you bring up was is a very
real reality i think more than likely
trent williams yes forced his way to the
san francisco 49ers oh you're gonna
trade me here well i don't know if i'll
play for them or if i do i'm i want 22
million dollars a year he did that and i
think that kind of forced washington's
hand to go okay you're gonna have to
send him to san francisco we're gonna
get a third and a fifth that's not that
bad and you know trent williams as it
sounds right now yes obviously is happy
with where he's going because it doesn't
sound like he's going to ask for more
money right now so he seems to be
content with the place he went because
he got to where you know this is where i
think he had circled all along
and here's the genius of it it never was
out that the 49ers were in play for
trent williams which prevented
anyone from washington specifically the
guy who signs the checks from telling
anyone over my dead body right it never
locked in no one ever had to take a
position that they weren't going to want
to back away from that's the genius of
it we had no idea that the 49ers were in
play until the cheese was standing alone
in washington with nowhere else to trade
trent williams because the buccaneers
had their tackle the jets had their
tackle the browns had their tackle the
vikings had their tackle
tough luck dan snyder if you want to
solve this now you only got one way to
do it and that's trading to san
francisco i'm telling you that this they
should write a book about how they
pulled this off i mean this is the
ultimate in nfl
four-dimensional chess that the 49ers
ended up with trent williams
well definitely you know and you know i
i've heard that there were some other
teams involved in this conversation too
you know so i think a lot of teams were
you know off the radar radar trying to
get their hands on trent williams of
course they were because of what you
mentioned you know what scott mcclellan
mentioned we know what this guy is he's
special that way but the 49ers yes did a
good job it just tells you again when
you're a well-run organization and you
do things the right way you can pull
things off like this even when you don't
have a relationship with the guy you're
doing business with because yes i have a
hard time sitting here thinking if dan
snyder had better options he would have
gone another way you know as we know
shanahan didn't speak very highly of the
redskins when the 49ers played them this
past season
and things didn't end well between the
shanahan family and dan snyder so
i was shocked to hear this i didn't
think it would ever happen but i think
because of lack of options and trent
williams wanted to go san francisco he
made it happened and uh it's it's a
steal for the 49ers
chris one of the reasons kirk cousins
isn't the quarterback of the 49ers the
second year that washington no doubt
dan snyder and the reports were out
there we ran a link to the story in
writing up the whole thing of snyder
holding his nose to do the deal with
kyle shanahan snyder in 2017 did not
want to help kyle shanahan did not want
to give him the quarterback he wanted
and he was able to ultimately derail
that because in the interim they traded
for jimmy garoppolo so by the time kirk
cousins became available it wasn't
happening in san francisco but there is
bad blood there people do hold grudges
and dan snyder and and kyle shanahan's
holding the grudge too though i mean
when when dad gets the game ball after
you go back to washington and beat dan
snyder you know and and what kyle said
the week before the game you made light
of this or not light of it be made
reference to it the idea they asked him
what he loved about coaching in
washington what he liked the most he
said being able to work with my dad and
other great coaches what'd you like the
least everything else was his response
so uh yeah no love lost between the
49ers in washington but still the
ability to get a deal done which makes
it even more impressive a couple of
other things the 49ers did this weekend
by way of trades marquis goodwin traded
the eagles that's not a bad deal chris
because they quit using marquis goodwin
he he he wasn't dressing for games to
get anything for marquis goodwin is
impressive and then matt breida one of
the many running backs they have traded
to the dolphins after breda said not
long ago he thought all the running
backs would be back this year well
they're all going to be back except him
well yeah i mean britain's he is you
know breeder the cheetah he's a home run
hitter but the 49ers i think look at it
and go hey he's got a little bit of an
injury history and we got pretty we got
pretty deep talent at the running back
position let's not forget jared mckinnon
might be back in the fall for the 49ers
this year and then you're right with the
marquis goodwin there's no role there
for him right now not between debo
samuel kendrick bourne and now brandon
iuk and let's not forget you know their
third round pick from last year jalen
hurt out of baylor he's going to be
healthy and back in the conversation
they still have dante pettis so there
was there was no more use for a guy like
marquis goodwood and you know i think
there is certainly a need there in
philadelphia for a speed guy i like that
you know i know they got jalen rieger in
the first round uh but but again you
know i think they want more than one
desean jackson if he pulls a hamstring
or pulls a calf muscle once again you
don't want your game plan to fall out
the window marquis goodwin can do a lot
of those same type of things that desean
jackson can maybe not at that high of a
level but the same theory and player as
at least
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports